Stéphane Guillon
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir Stéphane des souvenirs
je ne dirai rien sur les caricatures de
Mahomet dans ma chronique pour des
raisons d'assurance vie essentiellement
je vais dire un truc sans risque Benoît
XVI est une raclure et là je peux
rentrer à la maison en ciflotant donc
une chronique très noire Thierry mais
légèrement couille molle
politique bientôt à la retraite Chirac
s'entraîne au jeu question pour un
champion
comment expulser les sans papiers de
façon plus humaine c'est au rayon
boucherie à Rungis que Nicolas Sarkozy a
eu une idée tiens si on les pendait par
les pieds
une info incomplète du Figaro je vous la
lise samedi en fin d'après-midi Ségolène
s'est offert une heure de bonheur sous
la tente Pierre Bérégovoy alors qui a
offert une heure de bonheur assez Golem
on ne sait pas après les débats
participatifs les ébats participatif
aussi
pas facile de travailler après un câlin
regardez cette photo trois qui bossent
une qui revasse
comme tous les lieux publics l'Elysée et
non-fumeurs aucun changement pour
Bernadette et Jacques qui ne fumaient
qu'après avoir fait l'amour
dernière cigarette grillée en 77 à
l'hôtel de ville
[Applaudissements]
Bernadette a-t-elle refumé dans le TGV
piago seul David Douillet connaît la
réponse
après nous avoir piqué les Jeux
Olympiques de 2012 nouveau revers pour
Bertrand Delanoë l'Angleterre accueille
la grippe aviaire
le maire de Paris va construire des
bureaux dans des tours de 200 mètres de
haut avec très peu de parking donc tu
peux plus fumer tu peux plus de garer tu
peux te jeter
ouverture des tours macbrand en 2010
[Applaudissements]
médecine le greffé du visage s'est rasé
la barbe il paraît qu'il était furieux
bah il est brun et ils lui ont mis une
barbe rousse elle est vraiment et son
âge je m'en foutisme ces médecins c'est
vraiment une américaine a présenté à la
presse son bras biomécanique 22
fonctions possibles elle peut battre des
œufs faire du stop dire ce qu'elle pense
de bouche
satisfaire son mari ou casser des noix
on espère
on espère que c'est bien réglé
vie pratique la lingerie réparatrice à
la cote sans rembouret phosphèce et
gaine compresses cellulite attention
trompe l'oeil on séduit une fille on la
ramène chez soi et deux agrafes plus
tard ce n'est plus Laetitia Casta c'est
Évelyne Thomas
culture sortie du DVD Johny s'en va en
guerre
disponible également Johnny s'en va en
Suisse l'histoire d'un rocker qui a
troqué ses santiagas contre des Moon
Boots il s'emmerde tellement que même
son répertoire change blanc c'est blanc
il n'y a plus d'espoir chiant c'est
chiant il neige tout le temps
[Applaudissements]
télévision invité de marque Olivier
Fogiel Alain Delon refuse de poireauter
et s'en va c'est normal dans la nature
c'est la même chose jamais un requin ne
fait patienter un guépard
en ce moment les gens partent souvent
des émissions
pas ici
nous présente ses jumelles
une véritable provocation pour Pascal
Sevran qui souhaite stériliser les noirs
dans match peut-on sauver notre service
public s'interroge Alexandre Jardin
peut-on surtout sauver la littérature
d'Alexandre Jardin et on termine on
termine par le meilleur Ariel Dombasle
pose nu
la semaine prochaine la tête de la fille
de 18 ans qui a prêté son corps pour la
photo
sur le même principe Roger Hanin fera la
prochaine coupe du magazine
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
et mettez un pouce bleu